I can't believe I'm saying this,
but youtube has gotten stale lately.
Youtube used to be the place to go to
find cool,
obscure videos by independent niche
craters like this or this.
It was basically the antithesis of cable
tv where everything is sanitized and you
know exactly what you're wanting to get.
Youtube used to have an effect that I'd
like to call it,
they do to black hole where you get on
to see a retina link video and find
yourself three hours later watching
windsurfing fails compilation number
seven or the ultimate showdown of
ultimate destiny.
All through just clicking on related
videos in the sidebar is a bit like
going down the rabbit hole in Alice in
wonderland,
but youtube has made it harder to have
this experience or finding fresh
content.
This is a screen capture of when I
recently went to watch you Rhett and
link video on this channel.
Look at the sidebar options,
which should be the primary way to find
new channels.
The first page full is all written link
and the few options that are different
at the very bottom are channels that I
already have subscribed to.
There's absolutely nothing new to find
here.
How did this happen?
Well,
I did some digging and it has to do with
the Youtube Algorithm.
That's what determines what results or
favorite show up when you search
something.
It's exact inner workings are more
precious.
That garden,
the Krabby Patty formula,
but people have been able to figure out
pretty much how it works.
A few years ago,
youtube changes formula to favor watch
time.
In other words,
they'd rather show you a video that will
keep you on their site for 30 minutes.
Then one that will keep you on for 10
minutes and that makes sense business
wise,
but it's also why it's so hard to find
new channels on youtube.
Basically it comes down to this.
Youtube wants to suggest videos that it
knows you're already likely to enjoy,
but the only thing it knows that you
already liked is what you've already
watched.
This means it's only going to feed you
more of the creators you already know
and look,
I'm fine with being shown more about
subjects that I watch,
but it seems like lately that's all
youtube will recommend.
We need a new way to discover videos and
if any of you suggest the trending tab,
I'll put you through that wall.
It's just a bunch of TV,
late night host movie trailers or other
mass appeal videos.
I don't need help finding the youtubers
I already watched.
I know who they are.
I want to be able to find new creators
I've never heard of.
That's what made the youtube experience
special.
But Youtube needs to change its
algorithm to take more risks with
suggestions or we're going to all get
tired of watching more of the same
content he always watched.
In summary,
youtube,
you're getting boring these days and
it's time to spice things up.
Yours conditionally theaudience.
Hey,
what's up guys,
thanks for watching that video.
Um,
and you know,
I think the best video,
not the video that you found that you
were looking for,
but the one that you found that you
weren't looking for,
they're just right.
So if you guys have had an experience
like that,
reasonably let me know.
If you haven't,
let me know.
Thanks for watching.
You can subscribe here.
Watch another video here.
And I will see you guys next Wednesday.